today we are drafting and i want to make
sure i get this absolutely right so i
stay within the parameters of the spirit
of the draft these are the most mo movie
you know it was all going well until
then these are the most
movie-like
moments of the 2019 season peter king
gets the first pick if he gets the
trivia question correct here it is
now peter spoke with patrick mahomes and
his father pat mahomes for this year's
football for this week's football
morning in america column pat mahomes
played peter for six teams in his major
league baseball career for the first
pick in the most movie-like moments of
the year draft name three of the teams
for which pat mahomes played
uh the minnesota twins the boston red
sox and the new york mets
wow
that that apparently falls into the what
color is blue category for peter king my
goodness do you have the other three
you know the other three
uh he played for the cubs and the
pirates
and i forget who else
just looked at him this weekend that's
kind of a cheating
well yeah
the rangers were team number six
rangers yeah with a-rod yeah that was
the year that uh
that that was that was the year that uh
that young patrick who was five going on
six
uh learned all about uh playing
shortstop and all that so yeah i
remember
all right you get the first pick in the
most movie-like moments of the year
draft what do you got
all right so when i consider moments
you know i i there are some there are
some insta instamatic moments you know
and some single
moment moments but
i think what i'm going to do is lead
with the lamar jackson phenomenon i mean
not only does he run for the most yards
that any quarterbacks ever run for in
nfl history in a season
but he led the nfl in touchdown passes
and everybody said hey listen you're
gonna get hurt if you expose yourself to
this many hits well he never got hurt he
never apparently was in very much pain
can this last long term i don't know but
lamar jackson had the most phenomenal
season that a quarterback has had
in a long time and clearly one of the
most phenomenal uh seasons a quarterback
has ever had so i will take
the lamar jackson experience for number
one
yeah i like that pick and i agree with
you the whole season long a biopic
really you don't need any more from
lamar jackson but we're gonna get a lot
more 10 12 15 more seasons but this
season spectacular look here's what i
like in a movie i like suspense i like
to not know what's going to happen next
i like it to be something that can be
anything i have no idea i'm completely
in the dark about what's going to happen
next that's when i am fully and
completely entertained when my mind is
engaged when i'm braced for anything and
i have no clue what the result's gonna
be
so for me
uh the most movie-like moment of the
year was every single pass interference
replay review because it fit the profile
perfectly i never knew i never had any
idea what it was going to be it was
complete and total suspense every time
they came back from commercial and told
us what the official had decided i well
that's news to me because one week it's
here and one week it's there and then
it's this and you think it's going to be
overturned and it's not overturned you
think it's not going to be overturned it
is overturned so every week every replay
review was like sitting through a
a a whodunit or a some sort of
suspenseful movie with drama at every
turn and uncertainty abounds because i
had no idea what al river wrong was
going to decide for any one of those
replay reviews peter
i like that one and i think it is
bizarrely weird and
uh but not good for football that's for
darn sure um my second one is going to
be an individual play one of the
weirdest plays i have ever seen in nfl
history and that is the kicker to punter
uh touchdown by the miami dolphins and
and
you know so afterwards when i i think it
was jason sanders you know the kicker
who basically said afterwards hey you
know a lot of credit to our special
teams coach and to coach flurries for
calling this play but
i mean let's be real about this
you know when you see this play happen
from every angle you saw it happen first
of all the weirdest formation you have
ever seen in your life the offensive
line
is wide right in a bunch looking like
they're all going to be receivers look
at that
it's the strangest play
i'll i'll go i'll say this
that's the strangest play
in all my years of covering the nfl 36
years never have seen anything like that
so give me that
number two on the draft
i like that that's a good call now you
know a lot of times what happens in
movies like we say that's implausible
that would never happen no that's not
anything that we'd ever see
and then we see
art imitate life life imitate art
whatever the case may be and we see
something that happens in the real world
and we say well we wouldn't buy that if
it was in a movie script and i say all
that because of the moment that happened
on the thursday night in november in
cleveland between the steelers and the
browns when miles garrett removed the
helmet of steelers quarterback mason
rudolph and then whacked him over the
head with it that's the kind of thing
that you would expect to see in a movie
and you'd say oh that would never happen
in a real nfl game well it did happen in
a real nfl game to the uh you know
chagrin of the browns and to the
suspension of miles garrett for the rest
of the season it was not something for
the nfl to be proud of but it definitely
was a moment that you would expect to
see uh not in real life but uh in
hollywood peter
yeah i mean
so many weird things happen this year
you almost forget about it my my number
three
is going to be
you know mike when you talk about
what a cool script would be for
hollywood and let's give this one to ron
howard and not m knight shyamalan okay
because
it's going to be a little bit of a happy
story and here is the premise
61 year old coach
highly successful he's never won the big
one
24 year old quarterback off to a great
start in his career
and
loves 61 year old coach
a city that has not won a super bowl in
50 years that have gotten so close but
it's seen it it seems so far away
and in the first playoff game they play
they're down 10 and they've got to come
back in the second play or they're down
24 and they got to come back in the
second playoff game they're down 10 and
they got to come back in the third
playoff game
seven and a half minutes left in the
game
they're down 10
against the best defense in football the
best pass rush in football and that pass
rush is pummeling
the 24 year old hero
uh in this game
and what happens the 24 year old hero
comes to the sideline and says let's run
wasp do we have time to run wasp
and when he does that
the coach who's been calling plays all
his life
he wants to be the guy who calls the you
know the play that wins the super bowl
however he recognizes
hey
this kid is precocious he's beyond his
years he's so smart i'm gonna do exactly
what this quarterback wants to do
because i trust him
even though
this is the biggest most important play
call of my
life
they make the play call and this is why
it's got to be ron howard on third and
15
it friggin worked 44 year old 44 yard
pass
and they go on to score three times not
twice in the last seven minutes
and they win going away 31 to 20.
and afterwards the first words out of
the 24 year old quarterback's mouth and
i quote almost exactly
i really wanted to win this for andy
that to me
it not only could be a movie but it
should be
yeah you know it's funny because i had
the entire chief's postseason run that
and that everything about it is is
something that that hollywood would
maybe reject if you're
24 points down 10 points down 10 points
down that the offense is going nowhere
and all of a sudden you're gonna wake up
in the fourth quarter of the super bowl
oh sure right yeah that's gonna happen
and it did all right one more for me and
and i'm gonna
end where you began peter i'm gonna take
a liberty because you kind of have
already touched on this topic but but
another thing i like about
movies is a good monologue and there's a
short list of them that stand out for me
al pacino in and justice for all uh jack
nicholson in a few good men michael
clayton's uh encounter with tilda
swinton at the end er it was george
clooney's encounter with tilda swinton
at the end of michael clayton so the
best monologue of the year by far it
wasn't lamar jackson but it was about
lamar jackson here's our good buddy mark
ingram with his big trust speech from
midway through the season
now i would just like to introduce y'all
to the man the myth the legend
the mvp front runner if anybody else got
to say something different about that
then come see me y'all i'm right here
and be more outside the bank if you got
an issue with that come see me
about that
big trust
lamar jackson in the flesh yes sir
[Music]
that's that's mine that's that's just
that's uh that's the moment of the year
that's the non off the field moment of
the year is mark ingram in the big trust
speech and and that really was the
moment we all kind of said hey you know
what
maybe he is the mvp it was before it
became clear that he was the guy and
after that it became very clear he was
the guy peter
look you know
this was only the second year you know
of the mvp award that it was unanimous
following tom brady nine years ago
and
i i even though i made a big deal in my
column last week that russell wilson in
eight years has never received an mvp
vote there have been there have been 400
mvp mvp votes cast in his eight years as
a quarterback in the nfl and he's over
400
even though you know he's russell wilson
he's been pretty darn good but this year
and look the people who vote for these
awards you can only vote for one guy and
in my opinion
that kind of in the middle of november
was the moment that he started taking
off with the mvp vote not just taking
off with it but galloping away
on secretariat
that's when everybody started saying
this guy come on he's the mvp and even
though you wanted to give it the full
season and everything you really didn't
need to because by the middle of
december by like week 14 you knew the
baltimore ravens were having a very
special year and they had a very special
quarterback leading them
peter do you remember bob and doug
mckenzie
um is that right are they the canadian
what's that
yeah it's great white noise no i'm from
saturday night live yes okay yes yeah
yes yeah they i mentioned them because i
have one honorable mention selection on
the way out the door they had a movie
called strange brew which uh
would describe the gatorade that was
being stirred by the stack of cups in a
plastic wrapper in that monday night
game between the bears and washington
there it is go ahead enjoy the gatorade
no matter how filthy that plastic
wrapper of of cups stirring that strange
brew may be uh yeah sure that's gatorade
gatorade and all sorts of other stuff we
got to take a break
when we return what are the reasonable
expectations for the xfl as we move
forward we'll wrap up this monday
edition of pft live right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports